this is the Bienville legacy and on new
developments for three years actually
eight years of thinking even before that
we've made three concept motorcycles so
far one insult will be making 12 more
and we're taking pre-orders for those
now the engine hangs directly from the
center so if you can imagine a bow for
instance flexing you have two
independent Springs as a result and you
also have the steering separated from
the suspension this achieves a number of
important goals including reducing the
weight allows us to keep things
incredibly narrow incredibly light the
engine is a 1650 CC 180 horsepower
engine which all of the motorcycles will
be supercharged and one supercharged the
engine is 300 horsepower
edmc I supported master craftsman named
JT Nesbitt to build the ultimate
motorcycle and it's something he hadn't
designed for ten years and it took him
three years to build three concept bikes
so this motorcycle actually has many
different state-of-the-art components to
it it's built with primary components of
titanium and carbon fiber and so the the
bike itself has a bill of materials like
no other these bikes will start we're
doing bespoke production and we'll start
at 350 thousand dollars